welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab show I'm Michael chlorine and
I'm Alexander Chang coming up a little
bit later we're going to show you some
brand new google devices but first we
have some brand-new windows phone
devices yes we have two new brand new
windows phone devices the HTC 8x and
then the Lumia 920 from Nokia and these
are both running Windows Phone 8 yeah
that's Microsoft's newest platform
newest mobile platform at least Windows
Phone 8 which they announced on october
twenty ninth and both of these phones
are not yet available but they're going
to be available sometime in november
before Black Friday okay so as the
operating system on the phone what are
your impressions it's good it's really
good actually it's speedy it's different
I mean you get this whole like tile
based interface which is super new
compared to android and iOS icon-based
interfaces so I mean it's nice both of
the phones are super speedy they both
have dual-core processors now so
everything's fast and really intuitive
to use it's also it mirrors a lot of
Windows 8 right so like they start soon
yeah and I think it's in the little bit
of time that I've played with it I think
it's probably best for somebody who is
already well into the windows world like
right now this phone this new Nokia
looks a lot like the old nokia right
actually all the windows phones look
kind of alike they all have this kind of
funky blue color right and they have
like the same like frame around the
curved glass display is that a conscious
thing with Microsoft and its hardware
partners I don't know they didn't say
anything about it but I think colors is
definitely a conscious thing just
because live tiles are super colorful
would make sense for the hardware to be
as colorful as the operating system so
of the two new ones of the the Lumia and
the HTC which one's your favorite I
don't know at first this oh come on you
have to pick one I know
this one I really like this one super
thin actually I see it's HTC 8x but then
this one has like a way better camera
like significantly better camera yeah
it's on par with the iphone 5 camera I
noticed you to review the HTC you didn't
really like the cameras camera is the
gravity point mm-hmm well that's
interesting that that Lumia is too heavy
for me right let's help the same ready
about the old one too so if you want
like a pocketable phone this is
obviously not going to be the phone this
one will probably be the one you want if
you're thinking about windows phone at
least yeah and you can read all about
the 20 and the 8x and Alexandria
reviewed both of them on wire calm
alright Nathan's here and he's brought
with him the brand new google nexus 4
yep here it is it is fantastic I've been
using it for the last week and it's a
really really great phone he loves the
phone I love this phone what do you love
about it um well you know nearly
everything it's the nicest Android
overall Android handset I've seen come
out this year it's one of the nicest
android phones I've ever seen made ever
it's it's beautiful the build quality is
great the materials used are top notch
it's super fast it's lightweight the
display is gorgeous it has everything I
could want in smartphone and the
software it's the latest version of
Google's Android jelly bean operating
system but there's a bunch of like small
new features there's a future in here
with the camera where you can actually
take a 360 degree panoramic photo and
then you can upload it to Google Plus or
you can share the google maps so like if
you're in your favorite pizzeria and you
know it's not on google maps you can
actually submit that to google and if
they approve it they'll put it up there
now Google Street View team actually
built this took it to the Android guys
you know they the Android guys made some
user interface changes but this is a
great example of Google kind of working
with itself to build something really
cool for consumers the display
technology is LG the processors it's got
a quad-core processor and here it's just
it's it's super cutting edge in almost
every way except one pretty big omission
that was probably going to piss off a
bunch of people but there's there's no
LTE connectivity here 300 bucks for
eight gigs unlocked 350 for 16 gigs of
storage unlocked or t-mobile is the one
carrier right now currently selling this
phone and they're going to sell for two
hundred dollars on contract with 16 gigs
of storage all right but not as an LTE
device no it's now t-mobile doesn't
actually have an LTE network yet they
have a different type of 4G network
called hspa+ now what does that mean
well LTS newer in it and it can reach
higher theoretical speeds but t-mobile's
older LTE no 4G network not LTE is still
really really fast they're going to move
over to LTE they haven't done so yeah
but 18t starting sprint is barely
starting to get their network out there
verizon has a few hundred markets in the
US but in Europe and other you know
countries and continents LTE is and even
something that most carriers are
thinking of you know they're just barely
starting to get it started as well now
the reason why Google is skipping LTE is
because they want to sell phone all over
the world and HSPA+ networks gsm the
technology inside this phone allows them
to do that so that's why you got no LTE
here google isn't saying if an LTE
version will come out but that's going
to piss a lot of people off well it's a
strategy this work for them because
we've always recommended the Nexus
devices to people who are travellers
people yeah you know hop around from
country to country continent to
continent with regularity because they
perform really well under those
circumstances yeah and then this handset
will it's really fantastic phone I like
the ability to be able to buy it for 300
bucks or 350 off contract yeah and it's
got a really nice really really nice
screen on it LG really did wonders on
that now the last few we're done by
Samsung yeah yep yep but Samsung is no
longer Google's preferred and Nexus
partnership with LG on this one and it
you know this is actually the first LG
smartphone that are really no offense LG
you guys made some good stuff but this
is just way but that's really given
right so what is Samsung has been up to
in the Nexus line well actually Samsung
has been working with Google to build
this the nexus 10 which is Google's
first Nexus 10 inch tablet now their
first tablet was the nexus 7 which they
built with asus it was fantastic it's
still our favorite you know 7 inch
tablet here definitely the nicest 10
inch android tablet that i've ever used
the display is really really sharp it
actually has a higher resolution display
then apples retina displays on the third
and fourth-generation ipad and that's
that's quite a plane because right now
when you go to if you go to google play
their advertising the device and they
advertise it as you know the the best
screen available in 10 inch tablet yeah
and okay you know when you look at the
specs yeah the resolution is higher but
honestly you set them side by side and
they're both gorgeous
they're both insanely good-looking you
can't really tell no you can't you can't
really tell the difference like you zoom
in on text and it looks like it was
printed on a you know a piece of paper
but in daily use actual press practical
use this is this is beautiful the ipad
is beautiful this is the one for
consumers because all this stuff looks
great and and really the most compelling
part here for this device is yeah it's
got a top-notch screen I think that's
expected I mean Google really had to do
that if they did anything less than that
well no one would even want to consider
this but the user interface changes that
Google's made here they've made Android
easier to use you know they're putting
your contact front center just like they
did on the Nexus 7 with this my library
widget if you want to get rid of it and
you want to go back to a more old-school
Android experience you can do that too
you can move them all into one page
that's what I did yeah yeah one screen
exactly so you know there's a ton of
customizability here and this is the
best overall tablet experience on a 10
inch device that I've seen plus it's
super fast it's really nice and thin
light and there's this great like grippy
plastic on the back which does get you
know smudged up with fingerprints pretty
quick yeah but it makes it really easy
to hold with one hand for a 10 inch
tablet it's a lot more comfortable to
hold for a long time in the ipad if you
have tried an Android tablet and you've
not been super into it you have to try
the ones with Android jelly bean on them
that google makes the nexus devices
because it's a totally different
representation of android than what you
see on you know something like the the
galaxy note 10.1 totally you know like
something something a big tablet even if
it comes with an unflavored version of
android the google nexus devices always
get the over-the-air updates for anybody
else so you always have the most recent
version of Android and the way exactly
the Google intended you to look at it so
it's important if you're going to judge
Android and its merits is important to
judge it on these devices first yep I
totally agree totally agree d this is
the best 10 inch android tablet out
there I think she said a few more times
just in case people just tuning in now
they didn't quite get at ya how much is
this one by the way is 500 400 bucks
four hundred bucks what a bargain and
you could read Nathan's reviews on wired
and we
we'll see you next week all right